how are you how's life i'm good i'm good
you know we're doing the show
everything's good i'm a single dad i'm
taking care of that
okay i'm curious about that because i've
talked to you a bunch over the years
uh what kind of dad are you right dad oh
god
i wasn't challenging you yeah why do i
feel like we're in a pub all the time
the courts are wrong
[Applause]
i don't give a [ __ ] what the law says
no i'm a good dad i show up to i go
he's got a baseball game on right now
actually he's playing a wednesday game
and i'm not there i feel like in america
that makes a bad dad
you never came to my games but i'm
missing one for this so
that'll probably be put on the record
but he's getting to he's getting to a
stage now he's six where he's starting
to figure out
that i'm not good at everything really
you know like how you just go oh this is
how you fix this you show me how to do
shoelaces like oh this is good
and then he started to play baseball and
now he goes let's go in the backyard and
play catch and i'm
oh and it's just flying over you bro you
didn't are you a good athlete
look i will use the excuse that i've
never played baseball
is why i'm bad at baseball but i'm not
good at any activity
physical i'm not having
yeah nothing that covers everything i'm
not good at anything that involves
movement
really i and but but see this is a good
thing because i broke up with his mother
we're still really good friends
but she started dating this black this
real big guy from the ivory coast who
played professional soccer i think he
played in a world cup and everything oh
wow
and so what happens is your ex-wife's
boyfriend
yes okay yes great guy i think i've met
him once or twice
he seems all right and so what i do is
what i do is i delegate stuff off to him
it's like hank goes i'm trying to learn
how to ride a bike i go
your mother's boyfriend would be better
a little earn that prop
i don't that's such a kind of a weird
thing yeah it takes a village
yeah you know what you're very
comfortable uh
in this blender i'm i'm good at i'm
if my son wants to come to me with uh
musical theater tips that's what i
studied at university or wants to know
how to write a good dick joke
i'm your guy
[Applause]
no it's very it's very funny we're all
blending my lovely girlfriend
and um so she and all four of us are
going to go on a holiday
that's really progressive yeah we're
going to go on a disney cruise
just the four of us with a kid you your
girlfriend
and your ex-wife and her boyfriend
you're all gonna go on a cruise together
yes
okay yes it's good that's our society
works now
right in my kid's school some kids have
two moms some kids have two dads and
some kids have one parent and it's
normal now
it's the it's the kids that live in the
households that are like the waltons you
go something
creepy's going on in there yeah that
family's up to no good yeah
it's it's it's the families that have
stayed together
where you think that's that's why would
any why would
anyone stay together in a relationship
the smart thing that i did was i got
someone knocked up very early
right we weren't madly in love we had a
kid very quickly and then
halfway through we went ah geez we're
not into each other how about we become
friends and we went okay
it's the idiots who fall in love
and then have a kid and then love always
turns into hate
right wait a minute you don't
[Applause]
what love talent hey love and hate live
right next to each other
like is over here doing its own thing
love and hate are very close together so
what you do is people like try to save
marriages
don't wait till your marriage dies as
soon as it gets a cold get
out of there right you get out of there
right away you call it a day you go i'm
feeling a bit sick don't want to do this
anymore
people who go to marriage counselling
that's madness yeah
madness okay i have friends that i don't
get along with i don't go oh we should
go see a person and discuss our feelings
no
no horrible okay you get out of
relationships the kids are happier if
you stay in they see
fighting and stuff like that right i
thought i was coming out here to say
funny things it's become more
confessional
[Laughter]
than i
all right would this is this new this
new format is very telling i know
it's you just got out here and you got
you didn't see the desk and you got very
comfortable and then you just told us
love and hate live right next to each
other